The joe rogan experience.
You don't talk about Asians have your,
your reality of your situation,
like your family,
like you don't want to talk about though.
I talked to everything.
You tell everybody on the whole story what you did and why you can't go back to
Japan.
No,
I could go back.
I just can't get out.
You can't get out once you go back.
I would imagine so.
There's probably,
there's probably like a criminal record.
Yeah.
Tell it's a little different because tell everybody what happened if you want it
to mean this is an interesting story over.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
if you want to listen on that,
not a problem at all.
That's the only reason why I brought this up because I know you're pretty
adamant about expressing yourself all the time.
I,
I would say before I finished,
uh,
started the story that uh,
Dave was a wrestler in Japan September of 2003 in the same week I was in jail in
La County.
So I guess we were meant to meet each other,
but they apart 10 years ago,
this coming September,
we're in jail.
Oh,
someone sounds like a stock.
Correct.
That's exactly what I would send an email if I was trying to get them to get me
pregnant.
So what's your,
tell us your story.
So I got an email in August,
2003 from my cousin.
Basically my writing skill in Japanese isn't that good.
So he wrote it in English.
He basically could row pop up dead.
That's their nice went dead.
My father was dead,
but they didn't know how to write in English.
So that's the only thing.
They were well,
and uh,
I called them and find out my dad supposedly killed himself.
So wedding couple of days I flew back to Japan and find out what happened
because I saw him six months before,
early 2003.
Um,
I find out that my step mother was cheating on my dad before marriage,
during marriage.
And,
um,
they're trying to,
they're in process getting divorced,
but my dad killed himself later.
One.
We don't know for sure.
He commit suicide or my stepmother have something to do with his death.
We don't know.
But,
um,
during the funeral I sold my step mother killed him.
Do you think she killed?
I think so.
Why do you think that the more I hear the story,
she sounds like the most,
my,
my cousins older brought in Korea.
She was living in Korea at my stepmother.
So my cousins,
older brother lives in Korea,
their virgin FBI,
they've checked the background and my stepmother flew in the day before.
The last time they saw my dad alive.
Doesn't mean that he killed her,
but the,
she lies,
she killed him.
She said that she wasn't in Japan the whole time and we find out later why she
lied.
She lied about that.
Well,
she lied about that.
That's that,
that kind of guilt lying about where you were very suspicious.
Yeah.
So it doesn't mean she did it die.
How did he die?
Um,
hanging.
So I went to police station and saw the picture and he was in the hot sun for
like two weeks.
So he was dark.
I mean,
he looked like we just hanging outside inside.
But that summertime,
Japan,
it's so hot and humid,
a decomposing.
This is,
this is how I met Yoshi told us.
What was the joke?
It was the darkest joke I've ever heard in my life.
What did I say?
Told the joke.
It's a joke.
I just say,
you know,
he was darker than a nigger or whatever.
But uh,
Yo,
that is not a dark joke or even a good one.
But a racial slur darker than Bobby Lee's balls.
Yes.
So Bobby Lee have dark balls as black balls.
I can't.
Of course,
I can't approve of that.
That joke.
Do you don't say that on stage,
dude?
Yeah,
he did.
He did.
I was like,
this guy's crazy.
He's like,
that's ridiculous.
That's how you ended your act or somebody.
That's a good way to get your ass kicked.
Not yet,
but I'm going to have.
But basically he had been hanging and he turned black.
So he was hanging and basically the heat of the house just slowly cooked him.
Yeah.
I mean,
I showed the picture.
The cop told me,
I highly recommend you don't look at the picture,
but I needed to see,
you know,
because after his death,
my family farm,
he told me that all the horrible things that were have.
So do you think that she could have possibly driven him to do that?
Yeah,
for sure.
100% yeah.
Yeah.
She lived hundreds of thousands of dead.
And He,
she told my dad that she brought one of her cousin from Korea.
We later on find out it was her lover,
her the whole time.
So while my dad was working,
she was fucking this guy pretending to be her cousin,
whatever.
Just the whole humiliation,
debt and all that stuff.
And like,
was she younger?
10 years younger,
but this,
are you sure she wasn't just fucking her cousin.
This is why a guy like David should be afraid of marriage.
Okay.
Never ever,
never fuck someone where you're confused as to why they're fucking you or never.
But then
the reality is the natural law,
the world,
you shouldn't get laid,
Brian,
she'd get your shit together first.
But so,
so,
so that happens when you do that man,
people start to resent.
You ever see like a famous dude with a trophy wife and the trophy wife fucking
hates being there,
you know?
And you see that,
that that's a,
that's a sketchy situation.
Yeah.
I watched this dude and I watched his wife yelled at him and shit and he's like,
uh,
like this sort of minuscule famous guy.
He's a small guy and you know,
the wife was yelling at him,
I'm giving him a hard time and he had just,
he just absorbed it and dealt with it and it was really,
it really fucked me up cause this guy's really famous and I was like doing man,
why are you in this prison to abuse you?
This is fucking shitty person in your life is treating you like that.
Why?
Because she's not impressed with you.
Like what is it?
I'll tell you why some people wait a hundred and fucking 30 pounds and she was
six foot tall and hot as fuck.
And she really wanted to get fucked by Chinese black men,
Dingo time Mandingo or cause and maybe like when a guy,
when the guy is an old guy and he's got this hot young chippy and he doesn't
know why she's with them.
She's fucking stealing from you,
man.
Yeah.
So what happened?
So I went back to the funeral and um,
somehow she was,
she didn't know my temperament because my dad's a very kind and nice person.
He's never hit me before,
but I have temperament from my mother.
She was,
you know,
she was typical Korean women varies,
uh,
aggressive,
you know.
So I caught her at the funeral by herself,
uh,
preparing to funeral thing for my dad.
Right.
It was like way up a hill.
Yeah.
Way Up in the hill,
rest of the family of down the hill and parking lot.
They didn't know what's going on.
So basically I went up there with my aunt and my aunt's soul,
my stepmother,
and she goes,
you kill my fucking brother.
You fucking bitch.
He leaves.
It was me and her and everyone knows at this point that she was cheating on him
the whole time.
Oh yeah.
Everybody knows she the oldest of all.
She even tried to poison my dad.
So next thing you know,
she tried to poison.
They took the sample,
know those Korean dish,
Kimchi or whatever.
She brought from Korea.
My Dad kept getting sick,
so they took all the food from refrigerator at some medical lab.
They checked and there was a poison in a dish.
You're your stepmom is poisoning his Kimchi and hitting on and cheating on him
and the whole family knows and she has the fucking balls to go to the funeral.
When she was playing this thing,
she didn't know anything about.
Me and her older sister have a reputation.
I'm Marion bunch of guy and the old dying and Mr is circumstance.
Oh,
so they have a history.
They have a history of that.
Her and her older sister does the same thing.
This,
this sounds like it's crazy.
It's fucking insane.
So my aunts,
are you fucking budget,
kill my brother.
She left sounds and then 10 seconds later I just started running over and just
beating the shit out of her and I grabbed back of her head and start punching
their face for a long time and put her in.
She's unconscious.
No,
but she was shocked because she didn't know I had an inmate to do that and I was
a little surprised because I didn't plan to do that.
I was angry,
but I didn't take,
she was dumb enough to be separated by the rest of her family.
But she was arrested.
She was,
she was by herself.
You are by herself.
No one is anywhere near no one near.
And instead of grab her back of her head and just started beating her face in
stop and uh,
put on her ground and it starts stumping between her legs.
They're like eyeballs stomped her pussy stomach.
Then her face or eyeballs,
well to come out I was stomping her face like have to five or six times and I
heard some lady that work at the cemetery scream.
That's when I kind of just stomping on this lady and started screaming.
So how much damage did you do to her?
I think if I did it,
like my cousin called me in like week later and he was laughing,
he was laughing on the phone like yeah,
if you did it for another menu,
probably killed her,
whatever.
She ended up going to hospital for like two and a half,
three months.
But that snapped him out of it.
The lady screaming.
So then he ran back down the hill.
That's true.
And then like,
like everyone's like what the fuck's going on?
And he like grabbed his cousin's car keys.
No,
no,
no.
Yes.
I went down and uh,
my stepmother's nephew was walking up the stairs.
He didn't know what's going on.
So I started coming down and he doesn't know what's going on.
So I figured by then I already beat one person.
What difference does it make if I have,
so this guy goes,
peoples,
this funeral was how long after Japan,
but like when you got off the plane and went straight to the funeral,
right?
A day after.
Yeah.
So this guy gets the Japan,
goes to a funeral and then just starts punching people and then like,
so you attacked him as well?
For what reason?
Just because I feel related to her,
to her and like what difference does it make if I fuck everybody at this point?
Yeah.
It's like porn stars.
Like what difference does it make you feel about fuck one hooker or 500 once you
do one,
it's really interesting.
You're using attempted murder and connecting it to gang bang.
Oh,
Yoshi kills hookers all the time.
No.
And kills him with his aids.
So the animals are out a boy that a boy.
So I went down the stairs,
I saw him,
I sucker punch him.
He doesn't know what's going on.
Oh my God.
And there was a little,
uh,
feel bad for that.
No,
not at all.
But he,
I wish I want to do with it.
I know by was just angry with her and her family.
Right.
But mean her family is just people.
Yeah.
Don't feel bad of poisoning poisonous Pete.
Well,
you know what I mean?
Maybe they don't know what the fuck the sister and her dad at the time.
I didn't,
I wasn't really rationale.
It was just so angry.
So I sucker punching.
He went down.
It'll most of these eight,
I'm six foot one.
Most of these people are like five one five two.
So even though I'm not a physically imposing in America,
I'm pretty big in Japan.
You're kicking ass in jail.
I'm Anderson Silva when it comes to fighting and beating up old women.
But so how old was she when you did this to her?
55 or something.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
She killed his dad,
man.
Oh,
I understand.
Listen,
there's no [inaudible] I lost my fucking mind.
You know.
Listen,
I would've killed her.
I,
if I'm stomping on a check for five times,
she's dead.
I don't know how the fuck your pussy stomps allowed her to live.
So he knocks the,
knocks the nephew out.
I got this little,
it's not something to joke about,
by the way,
ladies and gentlemen.
You're right.
If your outrage listening to this,
you're like,
I can't believe he just got that little mallet where Buddhist scope to water to
clean that cemetery.
I grabbed that stuff,
just beat him one.
But the head Cup of times ran down the parking lot and it's still there.
My stepmother's older sister and her and her husband and then I started s sucker
punch him too.
It's punching everybody.
Yeah.
Punchbowl more endurance at this point.
You're getting winded.
Yeah.
I wish I would have stretched before that,
but I didn't plan,
it wasn't planning itself.
I don't know anything about martial art.
I don't let any of that stuff.
It was unplanned.
You beat all these people out.
How do you get out of the country?
Um,
my shit,
Mike,
my aunt Yoshi,
she's the only one when he started finding me back,
she's the one that,
she had a cancer brain cancer actually,
but she's the one that uh,
interrupted fight.
Stop punching him and just told me to leave.
And I told my cousin dragged me out of there and he wasn't sure cause he want
to.
So you punched him too?
No,
no,
no.
If I think he hesitated because he doesn't want a somebody who did criminal
acts,
but he's smaller than I am,
so if you don't take,
I'm going to beat the shit out of it.
Well,
we got in his car and he's driving me out of there and I went to Osaka
International.
He just got to Japan.
Yeah,
like a day before and then he went and beat everyone up and then he's hiding.
You got right to the airport?
I grabbed his cell phone and call the airlines,
changed my flight.
I'm praying there's another fly with the flowers and there just happened to be
one in four hours,
so I went over there,
but that was the longest full hours airport because I figure she'll call the
police and just hid in the bathroom.
What happened had they not call the police and never even occurred to them
because they were so worried about her.
They went to hospital.
Whether they probably didn't know where you went.
They figured out they figured out what's hiding somebody.
One of my cousin's house.
You think that they knew that she was guilty too?
Oh,
everybody knows she's the returns.
How did you find out it was your aunt that told you,
right?
Yeah.
It was her trying to poison him.
Huh?
Yeah.
Your aunt told you,
what did she say?
They have a medical record.
Someone this whole time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it doesn't mean she tried to kill him.
Oh No.
She tried to kill him because of the poisoning.
Now that's pretty definitive.
Yeah.
And they had a medical lab.
Uh,
I don't know how they figure a poison,
but they took it to the lab.
Ever Eat Kimchi at Yoshi,
his house,
he keeps his daddy stabbing.
Kimchi in general is pretty strong.
I love Kimchi,
Kimchi at Yoshi cells and it tastes a little weird.
Don't eat that shit.
Damn Dude.
So you escaped Japan.
Yeah.
And the other criminal charges pressed against him.
Here's a weird thing.
Mostly comps in Japan doing or be a part of like family dispute with technical.
She's still my family.
So whenever there's a fan of me at each boot,
they'd rather,
there's even a fucking head stomping.
Well,
generally speaking,
but um,
I don't want to go back to Japan.
To find out.
So when remember you,
and I think Jody's it.
D has asked me and like the goal,
but you can translate.
I would love to do it,
but I was little worried.
Maybe as soon as I land,
there's a record of it and put me in jail.
There could be right?
There might be.
You ready to record record?
Oh,
it is already.
What the fuck's on?